- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Avant de
commencer la séance de questions
au gouvernement, je voudrais
prononcer quelques mots.
Notre pays a la chance de pouvoir
compter sur des citoyens qui
s'engagent pour servir, protéger
et soigner les autres.
Aucun ne devrait avoir à le faire
au péril de sa vie.
Dimanche, trois jeunes policiers
sont morts dans un terrible
accident, dans le Nord.
Lundi, un agent de la direction
interdépartementale des routes
atlantiques a perdu la vie dans un
autre accident, en
Charente-Maritime.
Ce matin, une infirmière du CHU de
Reims est décédée à la suite d'une
horrible agression.
Au nom de la représentation
nationale, je vous demande
d'observer une minute de silence
en hommage aux victimes et en
soutien à ceux qui les aimaient.
Exprimons également ensemble notre
reconnaissance à tous les agents
du service public, qui oeuvrent au
quotidien avec un dévouement
exemplaire au service des citoyens
et de l'intérêt général.
Je vous remercie.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
je veux d'abord vous remercier
d'avoir rendu cet hommage.
Nous avons appris ce matin avec
une grande tristesse le décès
d'une infirmière violemment
agressée hier, au CHU de Rennes.
De Reims, pardon.
Ce drame s'ajoute à ceux qui ont
brutalement frappé les agents du
service public ces derniers jours.
La mort de trois jeunes policiers
dimanche, qui accompagnaient une
victime à l'hôpital, et ont été
percutés par un chauffard.
Ce lundi, c'est un agent
interdépartemental des routes qui
est décédé alors qu'il intervenait
pour la mise en sécurité d'un
véhicule.
Je veux rendre hommage aux familles,
aux proches et aux
collègues des victimes.
Je leur dis ma solidarité, la
solidarité de mon gouvernement,
comme l'ont fait les ministres qui
se sont rendus sur les lieux de
ces drames.
Mesdames et messieurs, s'engager
pour le service public, servir les
autres, protéger, soigner,
éduquer, ce sont des missions qui
honorent celles et ceux qui les
exercent au quotidien.
Leur engagement fait la force de
notre pays et notre cohésion.
A tous les agents du service
public, je veux redire mon émotion
et mon soutien.
Je veux assurer chacune et chacun
de la reconnaissance de la nation,
de la reconnaissance des Français,
qui savent leur sens du service et
leur dévouement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Applaudissements
...
Merci beaucoup, madame la Première
ministre.
La première question va être posée
par monsieur Xavier Albertini.
- Xavier Albertini: Mes chers
collègues, après la disparition
tragique dimanche matin de trois
policiers dans le cadre de leur
mission, hier après-midi, un
déséquilibré a agressé une
secrétaire médicale et une
infirmière au CHU de Reims.
J'ai une pensée sincère pour ces
femmes, qui exerçaient un
merveilleux métier.
Je présente en mon nom et au nom
de mon groupe ma compassion et mes
condoléances à leurs familles, à
leurs proches, à leurs collègues
et à toute la communauté des
soignants de ce pays.
Nous avons une pensée pour la
seconde victime, dont les jours ne
sont plus en danger.
Hier, au CHU de Reims, un homme
muni d'un couteau dans les
services a pénétré dans les
vestiaires pour commettre un acte
irréparable.
Ce drame met en lumière la
situation difficile de nos
soignants dans les hôpitaux.
Nos soignants sont trop souvent
agressés verbalement
et physiquement.
Cette violence a augmenté
entre 2021 et 2022.
Etre soignant, c'est aider
l'autre.
Aujourd'hui, cette communauté est
à bout.
Cette terrible agression met aussi
en lumière la difficile gestion
des malades atteints de troubles
psychiatriques.
L'homme gardé à vue était placé
sous curatelle renforcée.
Il avait été déclaré
"irresponsable des faits".
Nous savons qu'il était en rupture
de traitements médicaux.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé.
Une infirmière est morte hier à
Reims.
Quelles mesures comptez-vous
mettre en oeuvre, en lien avec les
travaux lancés en janvier dernier
par votre collègue, afin de
rétablir chez les professionnels
la sérénité qui leur est due et
leur permettre de se mobiliser sur
leur vocation première: soigner et
prendre soin des autres?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun .
- François Braun: Merci.
Cette agression mortelle qui a eu
lieu hier à Reims nous anéantit
tous.
Le personnel hospitalier et nous
Une infirmière est décédée des
suites de ses blessures lors de
cette agression.
Ma pensée va bien sûr d'abord à la
victime, à sa famille, assez
proche, aux équipes qui sont
intervenues sur place, les équipes
du SAMU, les chirurgiens, les
anesthésistes, qui ont essayé de
sauver l'autre victime.
Le temps est d'abord au
recueillement.
Cette agression nous fait
réfléchir et penser tous aux
risques qu'il y a, dans ces
métiers qui sont au contact de la
population.
On ne peut pas imaginer un hôpital
fermé.
L'hôpital est le lieu auquel on
accède lorsqu'on est malade.
Nous avions entrepris un travail
sur la sécurité des soignants et
les violences.
Nous attendons les résultats dans
les semaines qui viennent.
Avant même ces résultats, j'ai
décidé de réunir jeudi matin les
organisations syndicales et
professionnelles pour que l'on
accélère et que l'on voit tout de
suite s'il y a des solutions
possibles pour améliorer cette
sécurité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur David
Guiraud.
- David Guiraud: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, trois
jeunes policiers du commissariat
de Roubaix sont décédés dimanche
dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions.
Aux familles, aux proches et aux
collègues, je redis l'hommage des
représentants de la nation.
Applaudissements
Ces moments d'unité sont rares,
mais ils sont précieux.
Souvent, nous sommes en désaccord
et c'est normal.
Parfois, votre silence est aussi
incompréhensible qu'injuste.
Les salariés de Vertbaudet en sont
l'exemple.
Certaines employées ont 30 ans de
bons et loyaux services et n'ont
pas eu d'augmentation de salaire.
Les prix augmentent.
Elles sont entrées en grève pour
faire entendre leur voix.
La semaine dernière, le délégué
syndical de ces femmes a été
enlevé devant ses enfants par des
individus se présentant comme
policiers.
Ils l'ont menacé.
L'Intérieur n'a pas réagi.
Où est le ministre de l'Economie?
Puisque l'entreprise va bien, une
augmentation devrait être décidée.
Où est la secrétaire d'Etat
chargée de l'Egalité entre les
femmes et les hommes?
Pourquoi elle ne s'indigne pas de
cette direction qui a multiplié
les déclarations sexistes les plus
scandaleuses?
Où est le gouvernement?
Il devrait s'excuser et dépenser
son énergie pour convoquer le
patron de Vertbaudet à son bureau.
Parfois, nous partageons nos
peines et nos joies communes, mes
collègues.
Juste pour une fois, partagez
notre colère.
Gloire aux grévistes de
Vertbaudet!
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur le député, vous nous
interrogez sur la situation au
sein de l'entreprise Vertbaudet.
Peut-être qu'il est utile de
rappeler ce qui s'est passé dans
les dernières semaines.
Un conflit social s'est noué à
l'occasion des négociations
annuelles, début mars, au sein de
cet établissement situé dans le
nord de la France.
Une grève a été déclenchée le 20
mars.
A la fin du mois de mars, un
accord a été signé par deux
organisations syndicales, Force
Ouvrière et la
CFE-CGC, qui à elles deux,
représentent une majorité des
salariés.
Cet accord est majoritaire.
La CGT n'a pas accepté cet accord.
Je le constate sans porter de
jugement.
Aujourd'hui, ce conflit a entraîné
une médiation de la direction
départementale de l'emploi.
Cela s'est traduit par
l'engagement de l'entreprise,
formalisé le 1er mai, d'embaucher
30 des intérimaires pour rendre
moins précaire la situation du
personnel.
Le conflit dure encore.
A la demande de Fabien Roussel,
qui m'a alerté sur cette
situation, mes services ont
facilité la mise en contact de la
direction générale et de la
direction nationale de la CGT.
Des contacts informels ont eu lieu
la semaine dernière.
Une réunion s'est tenue hier
matin.
C'était avec la direction générale
de l'entreprise et les
représentants syndicaux
signataires et non-signataires de
l'accord de fin mars.
Une nouvelle proposition a été
faite, notamment avec le fait de
pouvoir alléger et renoncer à une
partie des sanctions envisagées
contre certaines salariées qui
étaient sur les piquets de grève.
Ces propositions ont été encore
rejetées par la CGT.
Nous souhaitons faciliter les
médiations dans le respect du
droit social et du dialogue
social.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Girardin.
- Eric Girardin: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de la Santé
et de la Prévention, chers
collègues.
Nous étions ensemble hier soir
dans ma circonscription, aux côtés
du président du conseil de
surveillance du CHU de Reims.
Nous étions en présence des
autorités judiciaires et de toute
la communauté médicale, sous le
choc suite à l'agression d'une
infirmière et d'une secrétaire
médicale, qui ont été sauvagement
poignardées par un déséquilibré.
Dans ce contexte tragique, vous
avez témoigné votre soutien aux
victimes et à l'ensemble des
personnels hospitaliers qui
doivent faire face à ces menaces
quotidiennes.
Vous avez rappelé la vitesse
d'intervention des forces de
l'ordre pour appréhender le
suspect, mais aussi et surtout la
vitesse avec laquelle les victimes
de cette attaque ont été prises en
charge par leurs collègues.
Malheureusement, malgré tous ces
efforts, nous apprenions ce matin
le décès de cette infirmière de 36
ans, tandis que sa collègue reste
dans un état grave.
Nous adressons notre compassion et
nos condoléances à la famille, aux
proches, à l'ensemble des
personnels du CHU et à la grande
famille du soin.
Applaudissements
...
Cet événement dramatique corrobore
les chiffres de l'observatoire
national des violences en milieu
de santé, qui décomptait en 2021
19.328 cas de violence,
d'atteintes aux personnes et aux
biens.
Chaque jour, près de 30
infirmières et infirmiers font
l'objet d'agressions sur le
territoire national.
Cette haine, la France ne peut pas
l'accepter.
Je souhaite rappeler ici, devant
la représentation nationale, le
soutien de la République à nos
soignants, qui oeuvrent
quotidiennement pour assurer les
soins des Français, en sauvant des
vies chaque jour.
Dans ce contexte terrible, comment
renforcer notre arsenal de
préventions au quotidien pour
faire en sorte que plus jamais de
tels drames ne se produisent?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Merci.
Merci de souligner, et je vais le
faire également, la célérité de
l'intervention de la police pour
maîtriser l'agresseur.
Je souligne également l'efficacité
de la justice dans cette affaire.
Ils ont mis le suspect en garde à
vue rapidement.
Par un hasard malheureux, j'ai
inauguré ce matin un salon sur la
santé.
Le président de la fédération
hospitalière de France est
également le maire de Reims.
Nous nous sommes retrouvés ce
matin dans ce contexte dramatique.
Cette agression était dans toutes
les têtes ce matin.
J'ai demandé une minute de silence
plutôt que d'inaugurer ce salon de
manière traditionnelle.
Il y aura également une minute de
silence demain midi dans tous les
hôpitaux de France en mémoire de
Carène Mézino.
Les soignants sont trop souvent
victimes de violences, injustement
qualifiées d'"incivilités".
Il n'y a pas de petites violences,
qu'elles soient par gestes,
verbales ou autres.
Nous ne devons jamais banaliser la
violence.
Je discutais ce matin avec des
soignants sur le salon.
Nous avons trop tendance à
banaliser la violence verbale ou
les gestes qui leur sont adressés.
C'est inacceptable.
Dans cet hémicycle, je sais que
vous condamnerez tous cette
banalisation de la violence.
Nous allons mettre en place le
plus rapidement possible des
mesures complémentaires, et je
tiens à rappeler encore une fois
la diligence de l'ensemble des
services publics, police, justice,
services de santé, qui n'ont pas
pu éviter le pire, mais qui ont
permis de sauver une des deux
victimes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Eva Sas.
- Eva Sas: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique.
Hier, a été remis à la Première
ministre un rapport établi à sa
demande, qui confirme à bien des
égards les analyses des
écologistes.
Oui, il faut accélérer l'action
pour le climat.
Oui, les plus riches ont une
responsabilité plus grande dans le
dérèglement climatique.
Leur empreinte carbone est trois
fois supérieure à celle des 10%
les plus modestes.
Il faut augmenter massivement les
financements publics de la
transition écologique.
Il faut financer ces dépenses
exceptionnelles par un prélèvement
exceptionnel.
Jean Pisani-Ferry propose un impôt
pour les plus riches.
S'attaquer au dérèglement
climatique est nécessaire, mais ne
suffira pas.
Vous avez lancé une énième
opération de communication autour
de la question climatique.
Vous semblez enfin ouvrir les yeux
sur les conséquences du
dérèglement climatique, mais après
six ans de communications, jamais
il n'y a eu de politiques à la
hauteur des enjeux, et alors que
vous parcourez les plateaux pour
annoncer que vous allez faire des
annonces, nous attendons des
engagements concrets.
Bruno Le Maire a déjà annoncé ce
matin qu'il ne suivrait pas les
recommandations du rapport
Pisani-Ferry.
Ma question sera simple.
Quand allez-vous enfin arrêter la
communication et vous décider à
écouter les économistes qui vous
conseillent d'investir dans la
transition écologique?
Il faut supprimer les niches
fiscales pour le climat et réguler
les comportements les plus
émetteurs, à commencer par ceux
des riches.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, madame la députée Sas.
Vous évoquiez le rapport
Pisani-Ferry, qui a été remis
hier, et vous en faites une
lecture qui consiste à le résumer
à une proposition au lieu
d'insister sur toutes ses
dimensions.
Ce rapport, d'abord, a été réalisé
à la demande du gouvernement pour
chiffrer le coût de la transition
écologique.
Il s'inscrit dans un chantier plus
large de planification.
Il est présenté le jour où la
perspective de construire une
planification écologique pour
arriver aux 270 millions de tonnes
d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en 2030 a été présentée, ce
qui est une première.
Il explique qu'il y a un besoin de
financements.
Il identifie trois pistes.
D'abord, réorienter les dépenses
budgétaires.
Ensuite, expliquer qu'on ne peut
pas traiter la question de la
dette pour tenir nos engagements
climatiques, notamment en matière
de rénovation, de la même manière
que l'on regarde les dépenses
publiques classiques.
Enfin, il dit que la question de
la fiscalité peut s'inviter dans
le débat.
Mais ce que je souhaite avant
tout, c'est vous demander
d'arrêter ce petit jeu qui
consiste à répéter des éléments de
langage qui tournent à vide et qui
sont faux.
Depuis que les écologistes ne sont
plus en responsabilité, le rythme
de baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre a doublé dans ce
pays.
C'est une réalité.
Si on avait écouté certains
d'entre vous, la filière nucléaire
et la capacité à produire de
l'économie décarbonée
auraient été touchées.
Heureusement, aujourd'hui, dans la
manière dont on construit une
planification écologique, on tient
compte de l'économie et du social.
Sortez de l'idéologie!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Madame Sas?
- Eva Sas: C'est encore de la
communication.
Je n'ai entendu aucun engagement
de votre part.
A quand les actes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Philippe Tanguy.
- Jean-Philippe Tanguy: Madame la
présidente, mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Comme l'écrivait Euripide: "Le
temps révèle tout et n'attend pas
d'être interrogé."
Les années passent et le scandale
de la privatisation des autoroutes
révèle notre système oligarchique.
Les mois passent et plus rien ne
justifie votre refus de reprendre
le contrôle des péages et des
équipements qui devraient
appartenir aux Français.
Les révélations s'enchaînent sur
la compromission du personnel
politique français, avec ceux qui
se gavent sur le dos des Français.
Marianne a révélé que le
secrétariat général du
gouvernement aurait dissimulé
l'indigence des documents de
travail qui ont permis de négocier
un accord en 2015 avec les
concessionnaires d'autoroutes.
Vous étiez alors directrice de
cabinet de Ségolène Royal.
Vous avez établi un accord
scandaleux qui a offert 9
milliards d'euros aux
concessionnaires privés
d'autoroute, dont la société
Eiffage.
Or, vous avez dirigé la branche
des concessions d'autoroute
pour Eiffage.
Ca vous fait rire?
Pas moi.
Comment avez-vous pu mener de
telles négociations?
Comment pouvez-vous ignorer les
bénéfices qu'Eiffage faisait sur
les péages?
Vous n'avez rien fait alors que
vous étiez ministre des
Transports.
Vous avez attribué à la concession
un contrat juteux.
C'est Eiffage qui a obtenu cette
concession.
Comment croire à votre
impartialité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Clément
Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, monsieur le
député Tanguy.
Dans le sillage de ce qu'a dit
madame la Première ministre au
service l'intérêt général, je
voudrais avoir un mot, si vous le
permettez, pour l'agent des routes
qui est décédé hier.
Je suis allé voir ses collègues
hier après-midi.
En tant que ministre des
Transports, j'ai aussi une pensée
pour les agents des routes qui
rendent service aux Français.
Je vois que ça ne vous intéresse
pas.
Je vais répondre à votre question.
Je vois que vous et votre
démagogie vous portez bien.
J'en ai assez, monsieur, de votre
démagogie au service de votre
électoralisme insupportable et de
ce complotisme de bas étage.
Vous parlez du secrétariat général
du gouvernement qui est sous
l'autorité de la Première ministre
et composé de fonctionnaires
dévoués.
Je ne supporterai pas que vous
jetiez le soupçon sur le
secrétariat général du
gouvernement ou les ministères.
A chaque fois que nous avons été
sollicités, comme encore la
semaine dernière, nous avons
répondu à vos demandes.
Nous avons transmis le rapport de
l'inspection générale des
finances.
J'ai transmis, la semaine
dernière, à la demande de
parlementaires et de journalistes,
une note de 2013 sur ce sujet.
On peut avoir un débat politique.
J'ai été des heures dans cet
hémicycle.
J'ai répondu à chacune de vos
questions sur les concessions.
Mais il faut cesser ces violences
politiques.
Nous ne pouvons pas vivre
dans ce climat.
Il faut arrêter
ce complotisme odieux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur Tanguy?
- Jean-Philippe Tanguy: Euripide:
"Parle, s'il y a des mots
plus forts que le silence,
le silence est un aveu"!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le ministre?
- Christophe Béchu: Vous n'avez
même pas de réponse.
Vous lisez des fiches.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Stéphane
Peu.
- Stéphane Peu: Merci, madame la
présidente, chers collègues.
Ma question est pour monsieur le
ministre des Comptes publics.
Tous les acteurs du logement,
depuis des mois, professionnels du
bâtiment, promoteurs, HLM, élus
locaux, tirent la sonnette
d'alarme.
Notre pays est désormais plongé
dans l'une des plus graves crises
du logement de son histoire.
On évoque même une bombe sociale à
retardement.
Cette crise est la source d'une
souffrance sociale.
Elle pèse sur le pouvoir d'achat
et affaiblit notre économie.
Depuis 2017, sur les bancs de
l'hémicycle, on vous a alerté sur
vos mauvais choix et vous n'avez
pas écouté.
Cette crise n'est pas le résultat
d'une calamité sans cause, mais le
produit de vos orientations
politiques.
C'est le résultat du rabotage des
APL, de l'augmentation de la TVA
sur la construction, en passant
par les ponctions sur les HLM.
Vous avez déséquilibré notre
système si singulier, basé sur une
économie mixte, avec un secteur
privé et un secteur socialisé.
Jamais la part du PIB de la France
consacré au logement n'a été aussi
faible.
Si le logement coûte 38 milliards
d'euros par an au budget de la
nation, il en rapporte 88
milliards.
Au moment où le secteur privé
souffre de difficultés liées à
l'inflation, il y a urgence à agir
pour redonner au secteur social
les moyens de remplir son rôle.
Ma proposition sera raisonnable et
simple: alors que la hausse du
taux du livret A pèse sur les
comptes des organismes HLM,
comment allez-vous relancer la
production, supprimer la ponction
et revenir au taux de TVA pour les
produits de première nécessité à
5,5% pour les constructions de
logements conventionnés?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Monsieur le député, oui, le
logement est un bien précieux, et
le logement social encore plus.
Le logement est au coeur des
préoccupations de ce gouvernement.
Le Conseil national de la
refondation sur le logement rendra
ses premières restitutions dès le
5 juin.
Nous avons travaillé avec plus de
200 acteurs du logement depuis des
mois pour faire des propositions.
Nous avons déjà agi, d'abord dans
le logement social.
Même si vous avez cité des
difficultés, le logement social
n'est pas en crise systémique.
Plus de 100.000 agréments ont été
donnés en 2018 et 2019.
Si une baisse a été constatée ces
deux dernières années, c'est parce
qu'un certain nombre d'élus locaux
ont pris des décisions contraires
à l'intérêt de leurs concitoyens
et ont refusé de signer des permis
de construire.
J'ai été élu local.
Je sais ce qu'un maire peut faire
quand il décide de construire ou
de ne pas construire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Silence, s'il
vous plaît!
- Olivier Klein: Pour faire face à
la crise actuelle, vous le savez,
il y a un soutien à engager.
Un programme a déjà été annoncé.
Nous allons continuer, dans le
cadre du travail que nous menons
avec Bruno Le Maire et les banques
pour l'accès au prêt, en
travaillant sur les possibilités
de souplesse sur les banques sur
les taux d'intérêt.
Tous ces chantiers sont en cours.
Le pacte de confiance qui a été
souhaité par la Première ministre,
sur lequel nous travaillons, est
en cours d'élaboration.
Nous y travaillons d'arrache-pied.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Belkhir
Belhaddad.
- Belkhir Belhaddad: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques.
Vous venez de lancer une
opération, celle de la billetterie
de l'Etat pour les Jeux Olympiques
2024.
Nous savons que l'accessibilité
des Jeux dépendra de l'Etat.
Nous avons abordé ce sujet au sein
d'un groupe de travail sur les
Jeux Olympiques.
Grâce à l'achat de 400.000 billets
donnant accès aux épreuves des JO,
le gouvernement contribue à
l'engouement pour les JO.
Les bénévoles du mouvement sportif
et les personnes en situation de
handicap ne sont pas assez mises
en avant.
Je rappelle que certains billets
sont chers.
Je n'ignore pas que les débats
engagés sur les prix des billets
sont présents.
Je rappelle que nous avons exigé
que les Jeux soient financièrement
équilibrés pour éviter de faire
appel aux contribuables.
L'opération Tous aux Jeux sera
aussi dans nos villes au moment du
passage de la flamme.
Pour nous, au-delà de la question
des billets, il s'agit de profiter
des Jeux Olympiques, notamment des
Jeux Paralympiques, pour donner
une vocation éducative et de
promotion.
Pouvez-vous, madame la ministre,
nous en dire plus sur cette
opération?
Précisez-nous la répartition et
les bénéficiaires des billets pour
les épreuves et la cérémonie
d'ouverture?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Amélie
Ouéda-Castéra.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra: Mesdames
et messieurs, monsieur le député
Belkhir Belhaddad, vous l'avez
dit: on veut de beaux Jeux, on
veut des grands Jeux et éviter un
impôt Jeux.
Il faut accepter qu'il y ait des
recettes de billetterie.
Les billets aux prix les plus
élevés permettent aussi de
financer les billets d'entrée de
gamme.
Comme l'ont demandé le président
et la Première ministre, nous
serons au rendez-vous de
l'impératif d'accessibilité
tarifaire et sociale.
Nous avons lancé ce programme de
billetterie populaire de l'Etat,
doté de 400.000 billets le 19 mai
dernier.
Il y aura des billets qui
viendront doter la jeunesse, des
élèves de CM1 à la terminale, en
métropole et outre-mer.
Il s'agira d'élèves défavorisés,
des élèves de l'Aide sociale à
l'enfance.
Ce seront des jeunes qui
s'illustrent de manière exemplaire
par leur engagement citoyen ou
associatif, des étudiants
boursiers.
100.000 bénévoles du mouvement
sportif, 17.500 personnes en
situation de handicap et leurs
aidants, ainsi que 25.000 agents
de catégorie B et C engagés dans
la préparation de ces Jeux, nous
allons pouvoir leur offrir cette
billetterie.
C'est un effort sans précédent et
inédit.
Les collectivités rajoutent une
dotation de 500.000 billets à
cela.
Le comité lui-même mettra 100.000
billets à disposition des publics
prioritaires.
Au total, c'est 1 million de
billets que nous pourrons offrir,
en complément des places qui
seront gratuites, sur les quais,
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture.
Nous voulons rendre les Français
fiers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Christian
Baptiste.
- Christian Baptiste: Madame la
ministre, madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs, mes chers
collègues, les travailleuses de
Vertbaudet dans le Nord se battent
pour une augmentation de salaire
et conservent une motivation
forte.
Si je fais référence à ce
mouvement qui est d'actualité,
c'est pour attirer votre attention
sur un événement majeur de
l'histoire de notre pays, les
émeutes de mai 1967 en Guadeloupe.
Les manifestations et les
affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre ont secoué l'île, révélant
les profondes inégalités
économiques, sociales et raciales
qui persistaient en Guadeloupe à
l'époque.
C'est pourquoi je souhaite aborder
la question de la déclassification
totale des archives.
Comprenez par ici que la
transparence est essentielle pour
guérir les plaies du passé et
progresser vers une société plus
juste et équitable.
J'exhorte donc le gouvernement à
prendre des mesures concrètes pour
la déclassification totale de ces
archives.
Les Guadeloupéens et tous les
citoyens de notre pays méritent de
connaître la vérité, d'apprendre
de notre passé pour construire un
avenir meilleur.
Ma question est donc la suivante:
suite à la décision du président
de la République tendant à la
déclassification totale des
archives relatives à la guerre
d'Algérie, pouvez-vous nous
indiquer les mesures spécifiques
que le gouvernement envisage de
prendre afin d'étendre cette
déclassification totale des
archives de même nature à
l'ensemble des territoires
d'outre-mer, la Guadeloupe y
compris?
Le cas échéant, quelles garanties
pouvez-vous nous offrir quant à la
transparence du processus de
déclassification totale des
archives et à l'accès de ces
documents pour les chercheurs et
les citoyens intéressés?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-François Carenco.
- Jean-François Carenco: Monsieur
le député Christian Baptiste, vous
évoquez un épisode douloureux de
l'histoire de la Guadeloupe et de
la France, les émeutes de mai
1967.
En octobre 2016, le gouvernement
d'alors a pris ses responsabilités
et le ministre de l'Outre-mer a
mis en place une commission
chargée de faire la lumière sur
ces événements.
Les conclusions sont rendues et
nous les partageons.
La secrétaire générale de la
commission a depuis publié
"Histoire populaire de la France"
où elle retrace les événements.
Il s'agit d'être transparent, mais
je n'ai pas de mandat pour donner
une version officielle.
Je ne peux vous en dire que ce que
j'en connais.
Le 26 mai 1967, des ouvriers du
bâtiment à Pointe-à-Pitre se
mettent en grève pour demander une
augmentation de salaire.
La grève devient une émeute.
Un militant indépendantiste est
tué.
Les armureries sont pillées.
Les émeutes débouchent sur huit
autres morts.
Concernant les émeutes de 1967,
comme sur les autres drames qui
ont marqué l'histoire des
Antilles, je dirais qu'ils ne sont
pas assez étudiés, non seulement
en outre-mer, mais aussi dans
l'Hexagone.
Je vais citer le rapport Stora,
qui dit que l'histoire des
Antilles, de la Guyane et de La
Réunion reste encore méconnue dans
l'Hexagone.
Après la fin des accords d'Evian,
celle-ci semble disparaître de
l'histoire nationale.
Nous devons travailler à la faire
connaître.
Le gouvernement est prêt à y
prendre toute sa part.
La mémoire, fût-elle terrible,
doit nous aider à construire
l'avenir.
C'est d'ailleurs ce que nous
faisons en ce jour du 23 mai où
nous célébrons la fin de
l'esclavage et où nous nous
remémorons toutes les victimes.
Quant à votre décision de
déclassification, je regrette de
ne pas avoir eu votre question à
l'avance, si ce n'est à l'instant.
Je ne peux donc pas vous répondre
tout de suite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Yannick
Neuder.
- Yannick Neuder: Madame la
présidente, mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Ce matin, un terrible drame a
frappé le monde médical de notre
pays.
Une infirmière du CHU de Reims a
succombé à ses blessures après
avoir été agressée au couteau.
Cet homme s'en est pris aussi à
une secrétaire médicale, la
laissant dans un état critique.
Je tiens à adresser mes pensées
aux proches de cette infirmière,
en tant que médecin et en tant que
député.
La facilité avec laquelle cet
individu a pu commettre cet acte,
le fait que son suivi
psychiatrique ait été suspendu, le
fait qu'il ait bénéficié en juin
2022 d'une ordonnance de non-lieu
pour une responsabilité pénale
restée sans suite, et surtout, le
fait que ce drame ne soit pas le
premier dans notre pays, tout cela
doit nous alerter sur une forme de
tolérance de l'Etat qui s'est
installée au détriment de la
sécurité de nos soignants.
On déplore une hausse de 23% des
incidents violents contre les
soignants, soit 1200 incidents en
2022.
Un record.
Près de 40% des professionnels de
santé hospitaliers ont subi des
agressions physiques.
Ils vont au travail avec la boule
au ventre.
Cet événement tragique pose aussi
la question de la prise en charge
psychiatrique.
Quand allez-vous fournir une
réponse à la hauteur de l'urgence?
Quand allez-vous financer un grand
plan d'ampleur pour la psychiatrie
et la pédopsychiatrie, les grands
oubliés de nos politiques de
santé?
A quand des moyens massifs pour
les structures de soins, de
recherche et d'enseignement?
Quand allez-vous véritablement
punir ceux qui s'en prennent aux
agents du service public?
Mettez à l'ordre du jour la
proposition de loi que j'ai
déposée avec mes collègues Les
Républicains pour rétablir les
peines planchers pour les
individus qui s'en prennent à ceux
qui nous soignent et qui nous
protègent.
Aucun soignant ne devrait risquer
sa vie à protéger celle des
autres.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur François Braun.
- François Braun: Monsieur le
député, je m'associe bien sûr à
votre soutien pour l'ensemble de
la communauté médicale, mais aussi
l'ensemble des soignants à
l'hôpital, ou dans l'exercice
libéral.
Le nombre d'agressions ne cesse
d'augmenter, souvent qualifiées de
petites agressions ou
d'incivilités, ce qui est
insupportable.
Une action forte va déjà être de
faire reconnaître ces incivilités
et ces agressions, de les dénoncer
et de ne plus les accepter.
Trop souvent, on accepte dans son
exercice professionnel de se faire
injurier pour une raison ou pour
une autre.
Cela doit rester totalement
inacceptable.
Concernant l'individu qui est le
responsable de cette agression, il
a été interpellé très rapidement.
Il avait des propos curieux,
semble-t-il.
C'est une personne qui a de lourds
antécédents psychiatriques.
Pour autant, l'enquête est en
cours.
Comme je le disais tout à l'heure,
laissons l'enquête se conduire
pour savoir exactement quelles
sont les circonstances, mais aussi
les circonstances globales et la
volonté de cet acte par cette
personne.
Concernant la psychiatrie, comme
les urgences, les maternités,
comme notre système de santé, cela
fait des mois et des années
qu'elle est en difficulté, nous le
savons.
Les assises de la psychiatrie nous
ont permis de mettre en place un
certain nombre de solutions.
Je pense aux maisons des
adolescents, je pense aussi à un
parcours psychiatrique qui a
permis des consultations pour les
gens les plus difficiles.
Nous aurons à continuer cela dans
une poursuite de ce plan pour la
psychiatrie, en recrutant des
professionnels, mais aussi en
travaillant sur le partage de
compétences.
Ce n'est pas en claquant des
doigts que nous aurons plus de
médecins demain.
Il faudra attendre 10 ans.
Il faut aussi des infirmières
spécialisées en psychiatrie.
- Yannick Neuder: Merci pour votre
réponse médicale, mais la question
est surtout pénale.
J'aurais souhaité que le garde des
Sceaux puisse s'exprimer sur les
peines planchers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Piquemal.
- François Piquemal: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur, pendant les
vacances de printemps, des
centaines de directrices et
directeurs d'école à Toulouse et
dans l'Hérault ont reçu un mail
émanant de vos services les
enjoignant à transmettre le taux
d'absentéisme le 21 avril, soit le
jour de l'Aïd.
Votre demande a choqué de nombreux
concitoyens, y compris le ministre
de l'Education nationale lui-même,
et pour cause, elle contrevient au
principe de laïcité, alors que les
autorisations d'absence pour fêtes
religieuses sont régies par le
code de l'éducation.
Elle dresse un lien entre la
sécurité intérieure et nos
compatriotes de confession
musulmane qui contribue à les
stigmatiser encore davantage.
Pour mémoire, le fichage religieux
et ethnique est interdit par la
loi, et cet événement nous
rappelle les heures sombres de
notre histoire.
Monsieur Darmanin, pouvez-vous
donc nous dire quel est l'objectif
de cette demande?
S'est-elle appliquée à tout le
territoire national?
Allez-vous demander le taux
d'absentéisme pour toutes les
fêtes religieuses et faire de la
participation à ces événements des
signes de radicalisation?
Avez-vous un problème vous-même
avec la laïcité?
Etes-vous prêt à formuler des
excuses auprès du personnel
enseignant et nos concitoyens qui
se sont sentis blessés par cette
nouvelle affaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Sonia Backès.
- Sonia Backès: Merci.
Monsieur le député, non, il n'y a
pas de fichage des élèves en
fonction de leur appartenance
religieuse dans l'école de la
République.
Mais oui, il y a un suivi sur tout
le territoire national du
déroulement général des fêtes
religieuses dans la sphère
publique, et il y a un suivi pour
toutes les fêtes religieuses.
Il y a un suivi des heures et de
la fréquentation des grandes
messes pour la religion
catholique.
Il y a un suivi du déroulement des
processions et des célébrations
pour la communauté juive dans le
cadre de la fête des lumières.
Ne pas suivre l'impact de ces
fêtes religieuses serait une faute
des services de renseignement.
D'ailleurs, ce suivi a été fait
également lors des précédentes
mandatures, et c'est bien normal.
Oui, la demande a peut-être été
formulée de manière maladroite,
mais non, demander des
informations générales sur
l'impact des fêtes religieuses ne
signifie pas de quelconques
intentions agressives à l'égard
d'une quelconque religion.
Vous demandez des excuses, c'est
vous qui devriez présenter des
excuses parce que c'est vous qui
affaiblissez la République en
étant d'une telle mauvaise foi.
- François Piquemal: Je vois que
vos réponses restent ambiguës, un
peu comme le rapport à la laïcité
de monsieur Darmanin, qui se
défausse.
Je regrette que vous n'ayez pas un
mot d'excuse pour ceux qui ont été
blessés par cet événement.
Ne vous en déplaise, à vous et à
l'extrême droite, au même titre
que la fête de la Nativité, que
Yom Kippour, l'Aïd est une fête
française.
La République est un bien commun
qui rend harmonieuses nos
différences.
Face à vos dérives, nous la
défendrons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Maud Gatel.
- Maud Gatel: Madame la Première
ministre, vous avez présenté hier
les premiers axes du plan de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre
afin de nous conformer à la
feuille de route européenne qui
prévoit une baisse de 50% des
émissions d'ici à 2030 et la
neutralité carbone à l'horizon
2050.
Le respect de ce cadre européen
est un prérequis pour faire face à
l'urgence écologique.
Suivant les préconisations du
GIEC, la France s'est engagée sur
une réduction à 270 millions de
tonnes de CO2 d'ici 2030, soit un
doublement de la baisse de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Le chemin qui reste à parcourir
nécessite une accélération
collective et la mobilisation de
tous.
Parallèlement à l'atténuation, les
efforts doivent également porter
sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique, car s'adapter, ce
n'est en rien renoncer.
C'est anticiper les conséquences
du changement climatique, dont on
sait qu'il touche davantage les
plus vulnérables.
Paris à 50 degrés ne relève
malheureusement pas de la
science-fiction, et les
conséquences seront majeures sur
les habitants, je pense notamment
à la question du logement.
La rénovation thermique doit être
pensée pour se protéger des pics
de chaleur qui rendront certains
appartements inhabitables.
Alors que le marché connaît une
importante tension, les politiques
d'adaptation doivent veiller à ce
que l'habitabilité soit renforcée.
Face aux phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes,
l'insécurité alimentaire, l'impact
sur la biodiversité et les
conséquences sur la santé,
l'adaptation n'est pas une option
et elle doit être socialement
juste pour que chacun y adhère.
Monsieur le ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires, vous
avez annoncé le lancement d'une
large concertation pour préparer
le troisième plan national
d'adaptation au changement
climatique.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer les axes
de travail que vous proposez pour
prévenir l'escalade des risques et
nous préciser comment le plan
s'articulera avec le fonds vert?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, madame la députée
Gatel, depuis ce matin, depuis la
fin de la matinée, la trajectoire
d'adaptation au changement
climatique est effectivement en
ligne, un document d'une trentaine
de pages réalisé par l'ensemble
des agences qui dépendent du pôle
ministériel et qui tourne le dos à
des années pendant lesquelles on
n'a pas parlé d'adaptation.
Même aujourd'hui, certains qui se
prétendent écologistes et qui
essaient de couvrir ma voix en
braillant n'ont rien dit sur ces
sujets, et aujourd'hui, ils font
semblant de dire qu'une
trajectoire d'adaptation à 4
degrés, ce serait la preuve que
nous aurions renoncé à nos
ambitions.
Je vous invite à regarder ce que
disent les climatologues et les
spécialistes.
On peut tromper tout le monde un
certain temps, mais on ne peut pas
tromper tout le monde tout le
temps.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: On laisse le
ministre répondre!
S'il vous plaît!
- Christophe Béchu: Certains
illustrent le respect qu'ils
portent y compris aux agences qui
ont travaillé, aux experts qui se
sont exprimés, en n'écoutant même
pas les réponses et en tweetant
plus vite que ce que les experts
sont capables de dire.
Je vais faire en sorte de vous
répondre.
Quelle que soit la vitesse à
laquelle nous allons baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
alors que notre pays a doublé sa
vitesse, malheureusement, quand on
le compare, les experts du GIEC
nous disent que nous ne sommes pas
sur une trajectoire mondiale du
respect des accords de Paris.
C'est entre 2,8 et 3,2 degrés
d'augmentation des températures.
C'est 4 pour la France.
4 degrés, ça veut dire repenser la
résilience de nos infrastructures
de transport, de
télécommunication, ça veut dire
mieux préserver la biodiversité.
C'est le sens de la concertation
qui a été lancée ce matin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Michel Castellani.
- Michel Castellani: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, au
moment où devraient reprendre les
discussions entre les citoyens et
les élus, je voudrais parler de la
Corse.
Notre île souffre de nombreux
problèmes sans que des solutions
adaptées n'aient jamais été
diligentées.
Une majorité de Corses et d'élus
se rejoignent sur la nécessité
d'un plan global qui passe par le
statut spécifique de la Corse avec
des compétences permettant
d'améliorer les choses.
Nous souhaitons une société
fraternelle et ouverte, mais tout
autant inscrite dans une
continuité historique qui préserve
notre culture, notre sentiment
d'appartenance commun et notre
personnalité.
Au-delà de cet aspect
institutionnel, restent posés des
problèmes majeurs.
J'ai demandé à plusieurs reprises
que nous soient communiqués les
comptes financiers de l'île.
Il est impossible de dessiner les
contours d'un statut fiscal que
nous souhaitons sans savoir ce que
les Corses payent d'impôts ou ce
que l'Etat verse.
Je n'obtiens aucune réponse.
Je ne réussis pas non plus à
obtenir la publication d'un
rapport national sur la nécessité
de la construction d'un nouvel
hôpital à Bastia, pas plus que
nous n'obtenons la
contractualisation de nouvelles
écoles.
Ces silences répétés sont
inquiétants.
La lourdeur des tâches qui pèse
sur le gouvernement ne doit pas
conduire à sous-estimer et à
écarter les besoins que la Corse
exprime depuis des siècles.
Nous nous sentirions tous grandis
si nous avancions enfin ensemble
dans cette situation pénible.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député Michel Castellani, c'est
une belle chose que de pouvoir
parler de la Corse dans cet
hémicycle à la veille de la
nouvelle réunion que nous
tiendrons avec l'ensemble des élus
de Corse pour parler de logement
et d'urbanisme.
C'est une question importante que
vous avez déjà évoquée.
Je veux redire d'abord toutes les
avancées qu'il y a eu en Corse
sous le gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron, la continuité
territoriale, et notamment le
travail que nous avons fait pour
convaincre la Commission
européenne.
Je crois que le président Simeoni
s'en est félicité publiquement.
Vous avez constaté que dans la
programmation de l'énergie, la
Première ministre a rendu des
arbitrages favorables à la
rénovation des logements à Ajaccio
et à Bastia.
Pendant le Covid, nous avons
soutenu encore plus que d'autres
territoires le territoire corse
parce qu'il y avait une aide
particulière à apporter, notamment
sur le tourisme.
La Corse souffre d'une démographie
médicale mauvaise.
Mon cabinet s'est rendu sur place.
J'irai rassurer moi-même le maire
de Bastia dans votre
circonscription.
Gabriel Attal a également
travaillé avec les services
compétents.
Nous aurons un comité stratégique
sur la fiscalité fin juin.
Tous les élus de Corse auront
toutes les informations pour
travailler sur ce statut
spécifique.
Croyez bien que la Corse est au
coeur des préoccupations du
gouvernement et au coeur de mes
propres préoccupations.
- Michel Castellani: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
Je n'ignore rien de la difficulté
de votre tâche.
D'autres se sont cassé les dents
sur la Corse.
Nous comptons sur vous pour
trouver des réponses à la hauteur
des enjeux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Thibault
Bazin.
- Thibault Bazin: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, aider
les Françaises et les Français qui
travaillent dur et qui veulent
bien élever leurs enfants, voilà
l'objectif affiché par le
président de la République dans
son interview du 15 mai dernier.
Voilà une noble ambition, mais
qu'avez-vous fait jusqu'alors pour
aider les familles de classe
moyenne?
L'inverse.
Vous avez confirmé des mesures
néfastes prises sous le
quinquennat de François Hollande.
Vous avez remis en cause
l'universalité de la politique
familiale en mettant sous
condition de ressources les
allocations familiales.
Vous avez confirmé la diminution
du quotient familial.
Depuis 2017, vous avez pénalisé
encore davantage les familles.
Vous avez raboté en 2018 la
prestation d'accueil du jeune
enfant.
Imaginez, des couples de parents
qui travaillent tous les deux avec
un revenu équivalant au SMIC ont
pu perdre jusqu'à 546 euros au
total.
Vous avez supprimé en 2020
l'indemnisation journalière en cas
de maladie pour les parents de
trois enfants ou plus, soit une
perte de 33%.
Depuis 2018, vous avez divisé par
deux le prêt à taux 0 pour toutes
les familles de classe moyenne qui
aspirent à devenir propriétaires
et avoir un foyer adapté pour
leurs enfants.
Le nombre de PTZ a été divisé par
deux en moins de cinq ans.
Vos décisions ont pénalisé le
pouvoir d'achat de nos familles.
Résultat: en 2022, seulement
723.000 bébés sont nés en France.
C'est le plus faible nombre de
naissances depuis l'après-guerre.
Il y a urgence à agir pour
vraiment aider les Français qui
travaillent dur et qui veulent
bien élever leurs enfants.
Quelles mesures concrètes
comptez-vous prendre pour mieux
soutenir ces familles de classe
moyenne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Geneviève
Darrieussecq.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Merci.
Monsieur le député Thibault Bazin,
vous posez une question
importante, c'est la question de
la natalité, et plutôt de la
dénatalité qui sévit dans notre
pays, comme dans toute l'Union
Européenne, et plus largement les
pays occidentaux, dans une
transition qui est relativement
longue.
En France, de 42 millions en 1950
à 68 millions aujourd'hui, mais la
natalité stagne depuis 1970 et
recule depuis 2015.
D'un autre côté, la population
vieillit, puisque l'espérance de
vie s'allonge, ce dont il faut
bien sûr se féliciter.
Il faut entendre l'inquiétude
exprimée par certains de nos
concitoyens et par vous-même, qui
redoutent pour certains le déclin
dans notre pays incarné par un
déclassement démographique.
Le taux de natalité est au
carrefour de tous les enjeux,
productifs, sociaux, culturels et
environnementaux.
Je voudrais d'abord que l'on
reconnaisse que dans notre pays,
le taux de fécondité est encore à
1,80 enfant en 2022, soit le plus
élevé d'Europe.
Nous étudions ensemble le recul de
notre natalité.
Le nombre de femmes en âge de
procréer est le moins important.
Le recul de l'âge de la maternité
ainsi que les impacts économiques
et environnementaux jouent un rôle
également.
Les politiques familiales sont
pour le gouvernement des
politiques importantes.
C'est le sens des chantiers
structurants qui ont été menés par
Jean-Christophe Combe.
Je pense à la réforme du
complément du mode de garde votée
en loi de finances de la Sécurité
sociale en 2023 et à la mise en
place du service public de la
petite enfance sur lequel nous
pouvons nous entendre.
- Thibault Bazin: Madame la
ministre, ce n'est pas suffisant
pour enrayer le déclin.
Si on veut assurer le
renouvellement des générations, il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin et
rétablir une politique ambitieuse
en termes de politique familiale.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à madame Emmanuelle
Ménard.
- Emmanuelle Ménard: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à la
ministre des Affaires étrangères.
Comme beaucoup de communes
françaises, Béziers est jumelée
avec plusieurs villes, notamment
une cité allemande, une ville
martyre en Syrie, une ville en
Ukraine, et depuis hier soir,
également une ville du sud de
Taïwan.
Il s'agit pour notre conseil
municipal de se ranger aux côtés
d'une démocratie menacée d'être
envahie par la dictature
communiste qui règne à Pékin.
Il s'agit de rappeler que ce pays
incarne les valeurs dont nous nous
réclamons à longueur de discours
ici même, à la tribune de notre
assemblée.
Ce jumelage a été voté à la
quasi-unanimité.
Une seule voix a manqué, celle de
l'élu communiste, mais cela
n'étonnera personne.
C'est dans ce cadre que je vous
demande de peser de tout votre
poids pour que Taïwan soit invitée
à participer comme observateur à
la 76e assemblée mondiale de la
santé.
Taïwan la première a alerté l'OMS
de cas suspects d'une pneumonie
atypique en Chine.
Nous étions en décembre 2019 et on
ne parlait pas encore de la Covid.
Dans la foulée, Taïwan a offert
des masques chirurgicaux à plus de
80 pays dans le monde.
Or, aujourd'hui, sous la pression
des autocrates chinois, l'OMS
refuse la participation de Taïwan
à cette assemblée au détriment de
la santé de tous.
Ma question est simple: que compte
faire la France pour que Taïwan
soit admise au titre d'observateur
auprès de l'OMS?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Madame la
députée Ménard, la politique de la
France s'agissant de Taïwan reste
constante.
Nous n'avons pas de relations
diplomatiques avec Taïwan parce
que nous ne reconnaissons pas
Taïwan comme un Etat, mais nous
avons des relations d'une autre
nature.
Dans ce cadre, la France est
attachée à développer des
coopérations avec Taïwan.
Elle le fait notamment dans le
domaine économique, mais aussi
dans le domaine scientifique,
universitaire ou culturel.
Oui, nous pensons qu'il est utile
que Taïwan puisse participer aux
travaux d'organisation
internationale dès lors que cette
participation n'emporte pas le
statut d'Etat.
Nous souhaitons ainsi que Taïwan
puisse à nouveau participer aux
travaux de l'OMS.
Nous faisons avec constance des
démarches en ce sens avec de
nombreux partenaires.
Le ministre de la Santé l'a dit à
l'OMS hier.
Notre politique est aussi
constante s'agissant du détroit de
Taïwan.
Nous sommes opposés à toute
modification unilatérale du statu
quo s'agissant de Taïwan et nous
sommes attachés à faire respecter
la liberté de navigation dans les
eaux internationales.
Cette position n'est pas que
déclaratoire.
Elle se traduit en actes.
Concrètement, notre marine
nationale fait passer des navires
dans le détroit de Taïwan.
Cohérence et constance, telle est
la politique de la France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Allez-y.
- Emmanuelle Ménard: Cohérence et
constance, peut-être aurait-il
fallu aussi un peu plus de
fermeté, comme d'autres pays,
comme le Japon, le Canada,
l'Australie ou d'autres encore,
qui insistent avec beaucoup de
fermeté pour que Taïwan...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Michaël
Taverne.
- Michaël Taverne: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Permettez-moi d'exprimer mon
émotion à la suite du décès de
Manon, Steven et Paul, policiers
au commissariat de Roubaix.
Applaudissements
Depuis toujours, les policiers du
Rassemblement National soutiennent
les forces de l'ordre.
S'il y a un groupe, au siège des
députés qui ont été policiers,
gendarmes, sapeurs-pompiers et qui
ont assuré la sécurité des
Français pendant des années au
péril de leur vie, c'est celui du
Rassemblement National.
Malgré votre communication, votre
politique de sécurité est un
échec.
Vous êtes présents partout et
efficaces nulle part.
Par contre, les démissions
s'enchaînent dans la police et la
gendarmerie.
Cela vous rend mal à l'aise.
C'est la responsabilité de votre
gouvernement et ce sont les
Français qui en payent le prix.
La police nationale aurait connu
10.840 départs en 2021 et la
gendarmerie 15.000.
La situation a empiré en 2022.
Les forces de l'ordre n'ont plus
confiance en votre politique.
Les motifs sont prévisibles: la
présomption de culpabilité et des
conditions de travail déplorables,
le laxisme judiciaire, une gestion
humaine catastrophique.
Mes chers collègues, vous vous
levez pour soutenir les forces de
l'ordre et dans le même temps,
vous refusez de voter une loi de
votre collègue de la majorité pour
lutter contre la récidive et
alourdir les peines pour les
auteurs d'agressions envers les
forces de l'ordre et les élus.
La prochaine fois, réfléchissez
aux conséquences que cela
engendre.
Monsieur le ministre,
qu'allez-vous faire pour remotiver
les troupes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le député, je veux
m'associer à l'hommage que vous
avez rendu aux trois policiers du
Nord.
A ce commissariat de Roubaix, vous
étiez présent, et je crois que le
député Sébastien Chenu était
présent également.
Il y a eu un témoignage touchant
du major qui a pris la parole.
C'est dommage que vous n'ayez pas
répété ses mots.
Je vous vois hocher de la tête,
c'est dommage.
Il a remercié nos efforts
collectifs pour leur donner du
matériel, des effectifs et du
soutien.
Il a dit que pour rien au monde,
lui et ses collègues n'auraient
changé de métier.
C'est dommage de ne pas l'avoir
rappelé, monsieur le député, parce
qu'indépendamment de l'émotion qui
ne vous a visiblement pas étreint
lors de votre témoignage, vous
avez mal interprété les chiffres
de la Cour des comptes.
S'il y a un quart des policiers
qui démissionnent, c'est des
policiers adjoints pour devenir
gardiens de la paix.
Nous avons ouvert des postes dans
la police nationale.
S'il y a des gendarmes qui
démissionnent, c'est pour devenir
sous-officiers, parce que nous
avons multiplié par 2 le nombre de
sous-officiers dans la gendarmerie
nationale.
Les gens partent parce qu'ils
partent à la retraite ou parce que
nous leur permettons de revenir
dans la réserve opérationnelle.
Vous devez retourner sur le
terrain.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Michaël Taverne: Votre réponse
est aussi mauvaise que votre
bilan.
Relisez le rapport de la Cour des
comptes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Gérald Darmanin: Manifestement,
il vaut mieux entendre un major du
commissariat de Roubaix qu'un
député du Rassemblement National
qui a envie de faire de la
démagogie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sandra
Marsaud.
- Sandra Marsaud: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique et de
la Cohésion des territoires.
60 jours de canicule par an, la
quasi-totalité des forêts du
pourtour méditerranéen touchée par
les incendies, la disparition
complète des glaciers de notre
pays, des maisons fissurées,
50.000 logements touchés par
l'érosion côtière, c'est un
scénario digne d'un film
catastrophe, où les températures
augmenteraient de 4 degrés.
C'est pourtant cette hypothèse que
notre pays doit retenir pour
anticiper les réponses à apporter
à travers le plan d'adaptation au
changement climatique annoncé par
le président.
Nos concitoyens prennent
conscience du réchauffement
climatique mondial depuis quelques
années.
Il a déjà des impacts concrets
jusque dans notre vie quotidienne.
L'accord de Paris a posé des
bases, avec des mesures appliquées
sur l'ensemble de la planète pour
limiter le réchauffement à +1,5
degré mais les engagements sont
loin d'être tenus.
Nous devons changer nos habitudes,
appliquer de nouvelles normes
techniques dans tous les domaines:
transports, habitat, industrie,
énergie.
La charge pour notre pays pourrait
dépasser les 2 milliards d'euros
par an.
La feuille de route du
gouvernement est claire pour
accompagner la transition
écologique.
Pouvez-vous présenter les
objectifs de votre démarche, vos
axes d'intervention et vos moyens
pour lutter contre la sécheresse
qui s'installe dans notre pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Madame la présidente, mesdames et
messieurs les députés, madame la
députée Sandra Marsaud.
A l'instar d'autres pays autour de
nous, comme l'Autriche,
l'Allemagne, le Québec, le Japon,
assumer une trajectoire de
réchauffement à laquelle nous
devons nous adapter n'est pas lié
à l'accord de Paris mais
correspond à ce que disent les
experts.
C'est une responsabilité politique
de premier plan.
D'un côté, on se bat pour ne pas
dépasser les 1,5 degré.
De l'autre, on regarde en face
l'ONU et le GIEC qui disent le
monde ne va pas dans la bonne
trajectoire.
L'objectif de la consultation est
de faire comprendre à nos
concitoyens que +4 degrés, ce
n'est pas juste pouvoir rester un
peu plus longtemps en T-shirt
pendant l'été.
C'est le sujet du dérèglement
climatique.
Les sécheresses sont multipliées
par 5, c'est la montée des eaux,
c'est une perte d'enneigement.
Les deux tiers des stations des
Alpes n'auront plus de neige
pendant une partie de l'hiver.
C'est aussi une multiplication des
jours de chaleur intense.
Pour faire face à ça, il y a
l'accélération des politiques de
baisse de nos émissions.
Il y a, en parallèle, dans cette
consultation, trois axes: modifier
le référentiel technique pour
faire en sorte que la totalité de
nos infrastructures, les réseaux
de transports, tiennent compte des
pics de chaleur, lancer un plan de
gestion des vagues de chaleur, qui
sera présenté dans les prochains
jours, modifier notre urbanisme
côtier, repenser nos régimes
d'assurance et de catastrophes
naturelles.
Il y a aussi les mesures qui sont
d'ores et déjà des mesures
d'adaptation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Anne
Stambach-Terrenoir.
- Anne Stambach-Terrenoir: Merci.
"Monsieur Christophe Béchu
présente: 'La France à +4
degrés'".
L'objectif affiché est de sortir
la France du déni climatique.
Mais ce n'est pas la France qui
est dans le déni, c'est vous!
Nous avons entendu le GIEC quand
il disait qu'il ne restait que
trois ans pour agir.
Nous avons vu les incendies, la
sécheresse, qu'avez-vous fait?
Rien.
Si, vous avez démantelé notre
transport ferroviaire et fait
construire un port méthanier.
Qu'avez-vous fait quand
l'Assemblée a voté 3 milliards
pour le train?
Vous avez tout balayé à coups de
49.3.
La véritable dette est écologique.
Elle s'alourdit tous les jours et
elle n'est pas transférable ni
annulable.
Le "champion de la terre" a perdu
un temps fou.
Il faudrait investir au moins 66
milliards par an à la transition
écologique et imposer les riches.
Avec son inaction et son obsession
de la dette, le macronisme nous
envoie dans l'impasse climatique.
Vous voulez que vos amis les
riches conservent leur mode de vie
destructeur?
Madame Elisabeth Borne fait mine
de vouloir respecter subitement
les accords de Paris et propose un
plan qui n'en est pas un.
Pas de mesures contraignantes, pas
de budget.
Nous n'avons pas le temps de vos
contradictions et de votre
irresponsabilité criminelle.
Allez-vous créer un impôt sur les
plus riches et emprunter
massivement pour engager la
bifurcation écologique?
C'est le plus grand défi de
l'humanité.
Nous parlons de notre survie.
Allez-vous enfin instaurer le
"Quoi qu'il en coûte" écologique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
députée, oui, c'est le plus grand
défi de notre génération et il
mérite que l'on sorte des
postures.
Votre fascination pour la
démocratie explique sans doute que
vous considériez qu'un plan, ça se
décrète sans concertation.
Assumez que votre bifurcation
écologique,
c'est du greenwashing
de la lutte des classes.
Quand on discute de baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
vous vous battez sur des symboles.
Regardons la réalité en face!
Ce que la Première ministre a
annoncé, c'est 100 milliards
d'euros pour doubler les
investissements ferroviaires.
Il y a la refonte de
MaPrimeRénov', la possibilité de
recourir au tiers financement en
matière de rénovation publique.
Il y a le plan pour les forêts et
les eaux.
Vous ne respectez ni les Français
par la démagogie que vous
véhiculez, ni le débat par le fait
que vous vous réfugiez dans des
"prêt-à-penser".
Depuis que ce gouvernement
est en responsabilité,
les émissions ont baissé.
C'était le cas en 2019, en 2020,
en 2021 et en 2022.
Il faut sortir de vos positions.
Vous y gagnerez en crédibilité et
le débat y gagnera en sérénité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Mathilde Desjonquères.
- Mathilde Desjonquères: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique.
Je veux parler du biométhane.
Alors que le gouvernement annonce
préparer notre pays au
réchauffement climatique avec +4
degrés, nous constatons qu'il y a
déjà des résultats.
En 2021, la France comptait 16% de
gaz naturel dans son mix
énergétique.
Au-delà des efforts engagés pour
l'électrification, les gaz
renouvelables et bas carbone sont
nécessaires au remplacement des
énergies fossiles.
Ils sont la seule alternative pour
la décarbonation de certains
secteurs comme l'industrie, le
transport lourd et de longue
distance ou l'agriculture.
Le biométhane est une énergie
produite par les territoires pour
les territoires.
Néanmoins, un certain nombre
d'acteurs ont besoin d'être
rassurés quant à l'ambition
nationale sur le sujet.
Certains soulèvent des freins à
l'investissement, parmi lesquels
la diminution de l'engagement de
l'Etat ainsi que les délais de
réponse et le manque de cohérence
des services déconcentrés de
l'Etat portant sur des sujets
techniques comme le mélange des
boues et des biodéchets.
Les questions sont les suivantes.
La prochaine loi de programmation
de l'énergie et du climat
permettra-t-elle de fixer des
objectifs à la hauteur des enjeux
dès 2023, en relevant la cible de
10 à 20% des émissions de gaz?
Quelles mesures le gouvernement
va-t-il prendre pour ce secteur?
Le gouvernement prévoit-il une
prise en compte du biogaz dans la
revalorisation mise en place pour
lutter contre l'inflation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Mesdames et
messieurs, madame la députée, je
vous demande de pardonner Agnès
Pannier-Runacher, qui aurait aimé
vous répondre mais qui est à
Bordeaux pour les assises de la
transition énergétique.
Votre question sur le biométhane
pose la question du mix
énergétique de notre pays.
Dans ce domaine, on a une
ambition: sortir de la dépendance
aux énergies fossiles.
Pour ce faire, on a deux voies
pour y parvenir: l'accélération
des énergies renouvelables et le
réinvestissement dans le
nucléaire.
Les mêmes qui critiquent parfois,
avec beaucoup de démagogie, la
réouverture de centrales à
charbon, oublient que des pays qui
ont décidé de sortir du nucléaire,
ce n'est pas une centrale qu'ils
ont fermée de manière temporaire.
Ils ont fermé des centrales avec
des conséquences qu'on n'a pas
fini de mesurer.
Le biométhane est produit
localement et il génère des
emplois.
Grâce à un programme du
gouvernement et à l'accélération
du soutien, notre pays produit
beaucoup de biométhane.
Dans quelques mois, nous aurons la
réponse à la question que vous
posez.
Est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
et se fixer comme ambition un
doublement de cette capacité de
production de biométhane?
C'est la piste sur laquelle nous
sommes.
Le biométhane peut être utile pour
plein de choses: pour remplacer le
gaz, en particulier le gaz naturel
dans des
chaufferies biomasse, mais il est
aussi précieux dans des secteurs
où nous avons du mal à décarboner.
Je pense à l'industrie lourde ou
l'agriculture.
Il faut baliser le chemin de la
planification.
La Première ministre l'a fait hier
pour pouvoir donner des réponses à
vos questions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Xavier
Breton.
- Xavier Breton: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
pourquoi tant d'acharnement contre
la filière de l'élevage?
Hier, la Cour des comptes a appelé
à une réduction importante du
cheptel bovin de notre pays.
Pour la Cour des comptes, cette
réduction devrait s'accompagner
d'une limitation de la
consommation de viande car
"un tiers des Français consomme
davantage que le plafond
de 500 grammes de viande rouge
par semaine prévu par le programme
national nutrition santé".
Mais de quoi se mêle la Cour des
comptes?
Nous aurions aimé vous entendre,
madame la ministre, ou entendre
votre ministre de l'Agriculture.
Le rôle de la Cour des comptes
n'est pas de dicter aux Français
leur mode d'alimentation ni de
prescrire la taille de nos
élevages.
Nous nous demandons même si cette
attaque n'est pas organisée
délibérément contre la filière
viande.
La semaine dernière, votre
ministre de l'Economie inaugurait
en grande pompe une usine
spécialisée dans les substituts
végétaux à la viande.
A cette occasion, il assumait
ouvertement la promotion des
protéines végétales, tout en
cherchant à disqualifier les
protéines animales.
Il indiquait que cette nouvelle
usine était "l'exemple parfait de
ce que nous voulons faire avec le
projet de loi industrie verte".
A quoi cela sert-il d'aller au
salon de l'Agriculture pendant des
heures si c'est pour mieux
poignarder nos éleveurs dans le
dos quelques semaines plus tard?
Nos éleveurs se battent chaque
jour pour maintenir la viabilité
de leurs exploitations.
Ils souffrent dans un contexte
économique compliqué.
Ils ont besoin de tout notre
soutien.
Quand vont cesser ces attaques
contre l'élevage et l'agriculture
de notre pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, monsieur le
député Xavier Breton, je vous prie
d'excuser Marc Fesneau, qui est
occupé au Sénat.
Il soutient le secteur de
l'élevage.
Bruno Le Maire a été ministre de
l'Agriculture.
Il est désormais ministre de
l'Economie, mais il défend
toujours l'agriculture.
Ce gouvernement soutient l'élevage
français.
Vous ne l'avez pas votée, mais
cette majorité a voté deux lois
pour soutenir l'agriculture
française.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
Laissez le ministre répondre.
- Roland Lescure: Des plans ont
été mis en place pour l'élevage,
en accompagnant la montée en
gamme.
La consommation de viande
aujourd'hui est en diminution.
Il faut moins de viande mais de la
meilleure viande.
Il faut aussi que l'on admette la
captation de carbone dans les
prairies.
Pour autant, il n'y a aucune
raison de se mettre la tête dans
le sable comme les autruches.
Le steak d'autruche, c'est très
bon.
La politique de l'autruche, elle
n'est pas bonne.
Je souhaite que la France puisse
être aussi sur le terrain de
l'agriculture et que des
industries françaises créent de
l'emploi en France, y compris pour
produire des produits végétaux qui
servent à nourrir nos animaux.
Nous ferons, sans caricature et
sans division, en sorte de
défendre l'élevage français et son
développement, y compris à
l'international.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christopher Weissberg.
- Christopher Weissberg: Merci.
Aux images du chaos qui ont frappé
Bakhmout ont succédé les images
d'un corps unique des pays du G7
avec le président Zelensky, qui
ont affirmé leur unité face à
l'agression de l'Ukraine par la
Russie.
Depuis le début de cette guerre
aux portes de l'Europe, il y a au
moins une note d'espoir.
Les alliés du G7 ne sont jamais
apparus aussi sûrs de leur unité.
Unis dans le soutien humanitaire
que l'Europe apporte aux
Ukrainiens.
Unis par un renforcement inédit
des capacités militaires
européennes et dans lequel la
France prend toute sa part, comme
en témoigne le projet de loi de
programmation militaire.
Unis aussi dans les sanctions que
nous infligeons au régime russe,
nous, Européens, en coordination
avec les Etats-Unis et les membres
du G7.
J'étais à Bruxelles et à
Washington la semaine dernière.
Les acteurs que nous avons
auditionnés ont reconnu que jamais
nos régimes de sanctions n'avaient
été aussi bien coordonnés entre
nos deux continents.
Cette unité entre les pays
s'arrête malheureusement aux
portes de cet hémicycle, à
l'extrême droite d'abord.
Le Rassemblement National est
passé d'une servitude financière à
Vladimir Poutine à une position
qui dénonce des sanctions
économiques qui "ne servent à
rien", pour les citer.
A l'extrême gauche, le leader des
Insoumis, nostalgique de la guerre
froide, entretient,
par son obsession antiaméricaine,
un clivage Nord-Sud.
La réalité que vous refusez de
reconnaître, c'est que ces
sanctions ont permis de frapper
l'effort de guerre russe.
Pouvez-vous nous détailler les
mesures annoncées par l'Union
Européenne dans le cadre de ce
paquet de sanctions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci.
Monsieur le député, vous l'avez
dit, le soutien de la France à
l'Ukraine est sans faille et il le
sera aussi longtemps que
nécessaire.
La venue du président Zelensky à
Hiroshima pour présenter son
programme à plusieurs pays en est
l'illustration.
Ce geste est une source de fierté
pour la France, autant qu'un geste
diplomatique utile.
L'unité du G7 est précieuse, mais
j'ajoute que les principes que
nous défendons, la souveraineté
des Etats, leur indépendance, leur
intégrité territoriale, sont des
principes universels, ce sont ceux
de la charte des Nations Unies.
Plus de 140 Etats, bien au-delà du
G7, ont soutenu, à l'ONU, à chaque
vote, les résolutions demandant à
la Russie de cesser son agression.
C'est dans ce cadre que la
politique des sanctions trouve sa
source.
Il faut amener la Russie à
constater son échec et lutter
contre les contournements.
Après 10 paquets, et bientôt 11,
adoptés par l'Union Européenne,
l'effet de ces sanctions est réel.
Les
activités industrielles baissent,
ainsi que les revenus des
hydrocarbures...
Tout ceci entrave l'effort de
guerre russe.
Cet effort, nous le maintiendrons
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra
car il est indispensable à la paix
juste et durable que nous
défendons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur David
Taupiac.
- David Taupiac: Merci.
La situation semble hors de
contrôle face à un virus virulent.
Au 17 mai, 33 foyers étaient
confirmés dans le Gers et ont
doublé en une semaine.
Face à la déferlante de la grippe
aviaire, les abattages de foyers
et les dépeuplements préventifs
ont repris.
C'était au moment même où la
filière commençait à repeupler les
élevages.
J'ai rencontré de nombreux
éleveurs en détresse psychologique
et financière.
C'était le sujet de mon
intervention au gouvernement ici
même, il y a trois mois.
Il y a eu deux épisodes d'épidémie
rapprochés qui demandent des
mesures de soutien renforcées et
rapides à destination des
professionnels de l'activité.
Il faut accélérer le versement à
100% de l'aide en 2022 et
s'inscrire dans la même démarche
pour les dossiers de ce début
d'année.
Il faut faire une remise à jour
des barèmes 2022 pour les
troisièmes et quatrièmes
trimestres qui ont augmenté
l'impact financier subi par les
producteurs.
Il faut soutenir les
professionnels avec la mise en
place d'une cellule pour les
accompagner.
L'espoir des éleveurs repose
désormais sur une stratégie de
vaccination dont les modalités
restent floues.
Vous devez accélérer sa mise en
place sans attendre l'automne
prochain, avec comme caractère
obligatoire une prise en charge à
100% par l'Etat.
Le gouvernement doit agir
rapidement.
Cette filière refuse d'être la
victime unilatérale de ce nouvel
épisode de grippe aviaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
J'excuse l'absence du ministre de
l'Agriculture, Marc Fesneau.
Il est actuellement au Sénat.
Il m'a dit de vous répondre, ainsi
qu'à votre collègue du Gers,
Jean-René Cazeneuve.
La situation nationale au regard
de la grippe aviaire était
assainie.
Aucun foyer n'avait été enregistré
récemment mais de nouveaux foyers
sont apparus, principalement pour
des canards, principalement dans
le département du Gers et dans les
Landes.
Le 22 mai, 67 foyers sont recensés
dans la région.
Nous savons les difficultés que
traverse la filière des éleveurs.
Cette résurgence de la grippe
aviaire a déclenché une réponse
immédiate de l'Etat, en
concertation avec les filières
professionnelles.
La mobilisation a été totale pour
mettre en oeuvre des mesures
sanitaires, comme une zone de
protection de 3km autour de chaque
foyer, complétée par une zone de
surveillance dans un rayon de
10km.
La surveillance sanitaire est
renforcée dans ces élevages.
Enfin, des mesures complémentaires
sont mises en oeuvre, avec des
zones réglementées supplémentaires
dans des régions entre 10 et 20km
autour des foyers pour créer une
barrière sanitaire
et contenir la contamination.
Cela permet aussi une détection
précoce des foyers.
Dans tous les élevages, le respect
des règles de biosécurité est
nécessaire.
Cette résurgence du virus souligne
l'intérêt de poursuivre les
travaux en vue de la mise en place
d'une stratégie de vaccination.
J'ai pris note des questions que
vous posiez sur le soutien
financier.
Notamment les mesures fiscales.
Je vais parler de cela au ministre
de l'Agriculture.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Hadrien Clouet.
- Hadrien Clouet: Samedi dernier,
France 2 invitait un témoin de la
violence sociale qui règne dans le
pays, un de nos compatriotes qui
exposait ses difficultés à nourrir
ses quatre enfants en achetant des
paquets de pâtes.
Cet homme, c'est Bruno Le Maire.
Il est payé 10.000 euros par mois.
Que faites-vous dans cette
situation?
Rien, à part promouvoir une
réforme des retraites inique
et scélérate.
A chaque alerte,
vous regardez ailleurs.
Les prix de la nourriture ont
augmenté de 15%, vous refusez de
les bloquer, mais vous êtes
disponibles pour voler deux ans de
vie aux Français.
1 personne sur 6 ne mange pas à sa
faim dans le pays.
Allez-vous accorder aux
associations les milliards dont
elles ont besoin?
Non, vous êtes trop occupés à voler
deux ans de vie aux Français.
Vous êtes-vous efforcés d'organiser
la hausse des salaires?
Non, vous êtes pris par la réforme
des retraites.
Les jeunes sont de plus en plus
nombreux dans les files d'attente
associatives pour recevoir
de l'aide alimentaire.
Avez-vous accordé le repas
à 1 euro aux Crous?
Non, vous étiez occupés à nous
imposer la réforme des retraites.
Vous êtes occupés exclusivement à
voler deux ans de vie aux Français
et aux Français.
Que fait monsieur Bruno Le Maire?
Il supplie devant le siège du
MEDEF que certains veuillent bien
diminuer leur marge personnelle,
mais vous êtes au pouvoir, donc
s'il vous plaît, gouvernez!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Geneviève Darrieussecq.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député, vous avez
raison, la hausse des prix impacte
les ménages les plus fragiles.
C'est une réalité.
Cette situation est la conséquence
directe de l'inflation alimentaire
qui existe aujourd'hui, et je
crois que face à ces difficultés,
le gouvernement agit depuis l'été
2022.
Premièrement, avec 46 milliards
d'euros dépensés par l'Etat pour
contenir la hausse des prix de
l'énergie qui ont un impact direct
sur l'alimentation, ce qui a
permis de faire en sorte que
l'inflation soit parmi les plus
basses d'Europe, avec également la
revalorisation anticipée de 4% des
prestations, pour porter
l'augmentation à 5,6% par an, avec
le trimestre anti-inflation que
portent actuellement Bruno Le
Maire et Olivia Grégoire, et avec,
en matière d'alimentation, une
action double, d'abord, le
renforcement exceptionnel des
moyens des associations d'aide
alimentaire, les crédits de l'Etat
ont ainsi triplé depuis 2022 pour
atteindre 156 millions d'euros.
Cela a permis d'affecter en
urgence 10 millions d'euros à
l'aide alimentaire à destination
des étudiants et d'apporter des
réponses spécifiques aux
outre-mer.
Enfin, par ailleurs, la lutte du
gouvernement contre la précarité
alimentaire se concrétise en 2023
par le déploiement du programme
Mieux manger pour tous: 62
millions d'euros pour cette
première année d'amorçage, ce qui
va permettre de financer des
paniers et des chèques solidaires
et surtout d'améliorer la qualité
des produits distribués.
Oui, nous agissons avec
pragmatisme sur le terrain et pas
par des incantations, comme vous
le faites en permanence.
- Hadrien Clouet: Merci beaucoup.
Vous avez lu 11 fiches.
Ca a l'air très intéressant.
Vous allez croiser les doigts en
espérant que les estomacs se
remplissent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Marc Tellier.
- Jean-Marc Tellier: Monsieur le
ministre du Travail, dans le
vacarme des promesses politiques
du gouvernement, le silence qui
suit résonne plus fort.
Dans une énième allocution, le
président Emmanuel Macron nous a
invités à bâtir un nouveau pacte
pour le travail.
Alors, comment expliquez-vous la
répression inacceptable qui se
déroule actuellement chez
Vertbaudet?
Les menaces de licenciement pour
faute lourde, les actes
d'intimidation, les violences
physiques et les arrestations
arbitraires se multiplient, alors
que les salariés ne se battent que
pour une revalorisation modeste de
150 euros par mois.
En majorité des femmes, les
salariés ont commencé leur
carrière au SMIC et la termineront
au SMIC.
Est-ce cela votre vision d'avenir
pour les travailleuses françaises?
C'est une politique qui maintient
les salaires au plus bas, en
particulier pour les femmes,
jusqu'à épuisement.
Nous rejetons fermement ce projet
de société.
Les travailleurs ne veulent ni de
petits chèques de l'Etat, ni de
primes d'activité versées par la
CAF pour simplement survivre.
Ils veulent un véritable salaire
versé par leur entreprise.
Nous exprimons notre total soutien
aux grévistes et au délégué
syndical qui a été enlevé devant
chez lui, devant son fils, menacé
et molesté.
Leur courage est immense et leur
détermination reste forte.
C'est aussi le cas des milliers de
travailleurs qui luttent contre la
réforme des retraites, pour une
augmentation des salaires ou de
meilleures conditions de travail.
Dans ce contexte, comment
expliquez-vous le silence du
gouvernement et l'absence totale
de l'Etat dans ce conflit social
majeur qui est une lutte pour la
justice sociale?
Ne serait-il pas temps de nommer
un médiateur?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député, l'Etat n'est pas absent de
ce conflit.
L'Etat est intervenu dès le début
du conflit.
La grève a été déclenchée le 20
mars.
Un accord majoritaire a été signé
à la fin du mois de mars.
Une médiation a permis d'aller
vers l'embauche d'une trentaine
d'intérimaires, et ces embauches
ont été concrétisées.
D'autres contacts ont été pris et
favorisés soit par les services
déconcentrés, soit par les
services du ministère, soit par
mon cabinet, directement après un
échange que j'ai eu avec votre
collègue, Fabien Roussel.
Cela a permis des échanges avec la
direction générale de la CGT.
Des propositions nouvelles ont été
faites, mais elles n'ont pas été
acceptées par la CGT.
Je souhaite évidemment que le
dialogue social puisse permettre
la fin du conflit.
Si le dialogue social permet
d'améliorer la situation et les
conditions de vie des salariés,
c'est une bonne chose.
Vous avez aussi évoqué les faits
qui seraient survenus à l'encontre
d'un délégué syndical il y a
quelques jours.
Mes services, comme les services
de la préfecture, ont pris toutes
les diligences pour essayer de
savoir ce qui s'était passé.
Le délégué syndical a été reçu
pour dire ce qui lui était arrivé
par les services de l'Etat.
Il a été encouragé à déposer
plainte.
A l'heure où je vous parle, aucune
plainte n'a été déposée, ce qui
n'a pas empêché le parquet
d'ouvrir une enquête.
Ce n'est pas mon rôle de
caractériser les faits, et encore
moins les auteurs des violences.
Cela m'invite toutefois à dénoncer
toute forme de violence, mais
aussi à garder une certaine
prudence.
J'espère que d'autres mesures vont
être trouvées.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Didier
Lemaire.
- Didier Lemaire: Merci.
Ma question s'adressait à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
J'associe à cette question Laurent
Marcangeli, président du groupe
d'amitié France-Italie.
Je n'aime pas parler de la pluie
et du beau temps, mais l'actualité
m'y contraint.
Il y a quelques semaines, je
questionnais le gouvernement sur
la sécheresse hivernale que nous
traversions.
Je vous interroge aujourd'hui sur
les pluies diluviennes déversées
sur l'Italie ces derniers jours.
L'équivalent de six mois de
précipitations sont tombées en
quelques heures seulement dans la
région de l'Emilie-Romagne.
On y voit plus de 20 cours d'eau
quitter leur lit, des crues
boueuses, des glissements de
terrain se creuser.
Humainement, c'est plus de 10.000
habitants contraints de quitter
leur domicile, et malheureusement,
14 personnes sont décédées.
L'ensemble de mes collègues
Horizons et moi-même, et j'en suis
sûr, l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale,
présentons toutes nos condoléances
à nos voisins européens.
La région touchée par ces pluies
diluviennes se trouve à quelques
kilomètres seulement de la
frontière entre nos deux pays, et
pourtant, très peu de médias
relaient la catastrophe naturelle,
humaine et économique qui se passe
en Italie.
Comme la France, l'Italie est en
stress hydrique, et l'eau tombée
ces derniers jours ne permettra
pas de le résorber.
On le sait, le changement
climatique dû à l'activité humaine
intensifie le réchauffement
climatique.
Notre pays a déjà vécu et vivra
encore des catastrophes
similaires.
Je salue le travail et les
annonces faites par monsieur le
ministre Christophe Béchu.
Cependant, j'aimerais savoir si
notre modèle de protection des
populations et de sécurité civile,
mais aussi de préparation des
territoires, répond à ces nouveaux
enjeux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Sonia
Backès.
- Sonia Backès: Monsieur le
député, vous nous interrogez sur
l'action de soutien suite aux
inondations survenues au nord de
l'Italie.
Les inondations en Emilie-Romagne
ont fait 14 morts et entraîné
l'évacuation de plus de 36.000
personnes.
Face à ce bilan dramatique, la
France a souhaité être pleinement
solidaire et a proposé dès samedi
l'engagement des moyens de
secours.
Si l'Italie n'a pas souhaité faire
appel à l'aide internationale dans
un premier temps, les moyens de
secours propres au sauvetage et à
la mise en sécurité des
populations étant insuffisants,
les Italiens ont sollicité hier
l'aide européenne.
La France a fait partir en fin de
matinée un groupe lourd avec une
capacité de pompage plus
importante.
Leur engagement est prévu pour
trois semaines.
Sur le territoire national, les
actions en cas d'inondations
seront dirigées par les préfets de
département qui s'appuieront sur
les services de secours et sur les
moyens de la sécurité civile.
Les services d'incendie et de
secours disposent de moyens
adaptés aux risques qu'ils
couvrent.
Ils disposent de 1325 personnels
formés au sauvetage en eaux vives
et équipés pour affronter les
situations à risque.
Le préfet peut faire appel aux
autres services d'incendie et de
secours ainsi qu'au personnel
militaire et de sécurité ville.
Ces engagements de renforts
financés par l'Etat sont
coordonnés en fonction des
situations.
Les 37 hélicoptères de la sécurité
civile et répartis sur l'ensemble
du territoire national sont aussi
à disposition pour effectuer des
actions de sauvetage ou mettre en
sécurité les populations placées
dans des endroits inaccessibles.
- Didier Lemaire: Merci pour votre
réponse.
Nous savons que la sécurité civile
sera incontournable dans les
prochaines années, et il est
indispensable dans notre pays que
l'ensemble des élus et des
citoyens prennent part à ces
enjeux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Romain
Baubry.
- Romain Baubry: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Pap Ndiaye.
Monsieur le ministre, notre école
publique va mal, mais vous la
fragilisez davantage encore dans
les territoires ruraux.
Ces territoires, symboles de
l'abandon de l'Etat, avec la
disparition de nombreux services
publics, continuent à être
le paillasson de la politique du
gouvernement.
A la rentrée prochaine, de
nombreuses fermetures de classes
seront mises en oeuvre, comme
c'est le cas dans certaines
communes de ma circonscription.
Les effectifs seront pourtant
à la hausse à la rentrée prochaine.
Ces décisions de fermeture
viendront surcharger les effectifs
et obligeront à créer des classes
à double niveau, créant un
casse-tête d'organisation.
L'efficacité des effectifs réduits
n'est plus à prouver, mais
les écoles de nos villages n'ont pas
bénéficié du dédoublement des
classes pour permettre aux enfants
un meilleur apprentissage
des fondamentaux.
Malgré cela, vous continuez
de creuser les inégalités.
Bien souvent, ces écoles ont créé
des classes Ulis afin de permettre
l'inclusion au mieux des élèves
souffrant de divers troubles,
mais vous avez fragilisé
leur scolarité
en les répartissant
dans des classes surchargées.
Réduire le nombre d'écoles et de
classes, c'est réduire les chances
de succès de nos jeunes
générations car les Français ne
mettent pas tous leurs enfants
dans le privé.
Nous sommes nombreux à vouloir
encore croire en notre école
publique.
Il y a quelques semaines, la
Première ministre a annoncé un
changement de méthode au sujet de
ces fermetures de classes
en zone rurale.
Les enfants de nos villages
doivent avoir les mêmes chances de
réussite.
Que comptez-vous faire pour mettre
fin à ces inégalités?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Monsieur le député, votre
département des Bouches-du-Rhône,
comme malheureusement de nombreux
autres départements, va connaître
une baisse des effectifs scolaires
à la rentrée, -1500 élèves pour ce
qui le concerne.
Dans votre circonscription à elle
seule, ce sont 252 élèves dans le
premier degré que l'on va compter
en moins.
Si on avait appliqué une règle
purement arithmétique, ce sont
donc 10 classes que nous aurions
fermées dans votre
circonscription.
Or nous n'en fermons que deux
d'un côté pour en ouvrir deux autres
dans deux communes qui connaissent
une croissance de leurs effectifs
scolaires.
Pour ce qui concerne
les Bouches-du-Rhône
plus généralement,
à la dotation initiale,
nous venons d'ajouter
22 postes
de professeurs des écoles.
Nous allons passer de 23,2
à 22,3 élèves par classe.
Dans les semaines à venir,
en fonction aussi des remontées des
élus de terrain, nous allons
procéder à d'ultimes ajustements
de manière à ce que la situation
soit stabilisée pour la rentrée à
venir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Romain Baubry: Vos chiffres ne
sont pas bons.
Il y a bien plus que deux
fermetures de classes
sur ma circonscription.
Les effectifs à la rentrée prochaine
sont déjà prévus à la hausse,
mais vous continuez
à vouloir fermer une des classes.
- Pap Ndiaye: Vous vous êtes
entretenu avec la directrice
académique des services
de l'Education nationale
la semaine dernière.
Je l'ai eue au téléphone
il y a quelques jours.
C'est elle qui m'a communiqué
les chiffres que je vous donne.
Nous pouvons vous les préciser,
si vous le souhaitez.
Nous sommes à l'écoute des élus.
Nous devons aussi tenir compte
d'une réalité, c'est la baisse
accélérée des effectifs scolaires
partout en France: -80 000 élèves
à la rentrée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Fatiha
Keloua Hachi.
- Fatiha Keloua Hachi: Merci.
Ma question s'adressait à madame
la Première ministre, mais je vois
qu'elle s'est absentée.
Je vais donc poser ma question à
tous les ministres
qui restent au banc.
Où est passé votre projet de loi
visant à inscrire le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution?
Le 24 novembre, l'Assemblée
nationale a voté pour cette grande
avancée pour le droit des femmes.
Le 1er février,
c'était au tour du Sénat.
Le 8 mars, le président de
la République annonçait un projet de
loi constitutionnelle
dans les prochains mois
pour inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution.
Et puis, rien dans votre feuille
de route des 100 prochains jours
dévoilée le 26 avril dernier,
rien dans les discours télévisés du
président de la République
qui appelait à l'apaisement.
Mais nous, parlementaires
féministes, nous n'avons pas
oublié cette promesse.
Vous voulez apaiser?
Commencez par tenir
vos engagements.
81% des Françaises et des Français
attendent cette inscription dans
la Constitution.
Le droit des femmes n'est pas
un jeu.
Ce n'est pas un slogan politique
et encore moins un prétexte
pour faire des promesses lâchées
opportunément un 8 mars.
L'enjeu est bien trop important
pour noyer dans une révision
constitutionnelle fourre-tout.
Nous attendons
votre projet de loi.
Vous le savez, le véhicule
législatif le plus efficace pour
modifier la Constitution reste un
projet de loi qui serait soumis au
Parlement réuni en Congrès.
Les parlementaires vous ont déjà
démontré qu'ils voteraient.
C'est à votre tour de prendre vos
responsabilités.
Vous semblez avoir des calendriers
pour tous les sujets:
la casse du lycée professionnel,
la stigmatisation des plus précaires
et la diabolisation des étrangers...
Mes chers ministres, où en est
le projet de loi pour faire entrer
le droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Madame la
députée, la réponse va être brève
car elle est dans la question.
Vous avez dit, madame la députée,
que le président de la République
avait dit "dans les mois à venir".
Vous avez rappelé qu'il avait dit
ça le 8 mars.
Mars, avril, mai.
Ne soyez pas impatiente,
ça arrive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame
Caroline Yadan.
- Caroline Yadan: Je vous
remercie.
Cette question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Monsieur le ministre, la
connaissance et l'éducation
permettent l'expression de la
liberté dans une démocratie.
En transmettant leur savoir et en
valorisant les compétences des
élèves, les enseignants
participent à la construction de
notre société.
Ils permettent à nos enfants de
préparer leur avenir.
La revalorisation des salaires du
corps enseignant
que vous avez annoncée
est l'expression concrète
de cette juste reconnaissance.
Garants des valeurs de la
République qui nous unissent, nos
professeurs sont depuis quelques
années en première ligne quand la
laïcité est attaquée.
Une enquête publiée le 8 mars
dernier a révélé qu'un tiers des
personnels de direction confrontés
à des atteintes à la laïcité ne
faisaient pas remonter ces
signalements.
C'est pour répondre à cette
urgence républicaine et aux
demandes des enseignants que le
Conseil des sages de la laïcité a
été créé en 2018 en exerçant pour
les questions nationales une
mission de conseil, d'expertise et
d'études relatives à la mise en
oeuvre du principe de laïcité.
C'est dans ce contexte que vous
avez annoncé le 14 avril dernier
la nomination de cinq nouveaux
membres au sein du Conseil des
sages.
Parmi les nouvelles nominations
figure celle d'un homme dont
certains propos ont suscité des
inquiétudes quand il a dit ne pas
défendre la dimension
émancipatrice de la laïcité et lui
préférait sa dimension
anglo-saxonne.
La ligne du président de la
République et de notre majorité
est claire: faire bénéficier à
chacun de nos enfants de la force
du principe de laïcité et de
l'universalisme républicain.
Pouvez-vous dès lors nous indiquer
votre feuille de route en la
matière?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Madame la députée, comme vous le
savez sans doute, c'est moi qui ai
demandé à ce qu'une publication
des chiffres mensuels des
atteintes à la laïcité soit faite.
C'est ce que nous faisons mois
après mois depuis le mois de
septembre.
Les chiffres sont affichés sur le
site du ministère de l'Education
nationale.
C'est moi également, en accord
avec la Première ministre et le
président de la République, qui ai
souhaité renforcer les équipes.
C'est aujourd'hui plus de 650
personnes à travers le territoire
qui répondent aux sollicitations,
qui forment également les
personnels.
Nous avons accentué la formation
des personnels.
Plus de 5000 chefs d'établissement
et leurs adjoints ont été formés
depuis le mois de novembre, y
compris à propos des remontées.
En effet, il faut faire remonter
les atteintes à la laïcité.
Je peux vous dire que nous
progressons en la matière,
particulièrement depuis le mois de
janvier.
C'est moi qui ai renforcé les
mesures disciplinaires en cas
d'atteinte à la laïcité en
diffusant des circulaires très
claires auprès des chefs
d'établissement.
C'est nous qui avons aussi
institutionnalisé le Conseil des
sages de la laïcité et des valeurs
de la République en lui donnant
une assise juridique qu'il n'avait
pas jusqu'à présent, en confirmant
ses membres, y compris la
présidente, et en confirmant les
principes mêmes qui régissent
l'action et le travail de ce
Conseil très précieux et avec qui
j'échange très régulièrement.
Madame la députée, vous m'appelez
à réaffirmer cet engagement sans
faille, je le fais volontiers en
rappelant que le principe de
laïcité, ce n'est pas seulement
une crainte ou une sanction.
La laïcité doit être aussi
appréciée.
Comme le disait Jean Jaurès:
"La République doit être
laïque et sociale.
Elle ne sera laïque que
lorsqu'elle aura su être sociale."
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est
à madame Sabrina Sebaihi.
- Sabrina Sebaihi: Merci.
Ma question s'adressait
au ministre de l'Intérieur,
mais je vois qu'il n'est plus là.
Je vais quand même la poser.
J'ai écouté avec consternation
votre réponse à mon collègue
François Piquemal concernant
le fichage des enfants
le jour de l'Aïd.
Encore une fois,
vous répondez à côté.
Avez-vous ciblé les élèves
musulmans le 21 avril dernier?
Vous répondez complètement à côté
en donnant l'exemple du suivi
des processions religieuses
ou de la messe le dimanche
dans l'espace public, alors
que l'on vous parle de l'école.
Vous vous permettez même
de vous défausser sur les majorités
précédentes et vous bredouillez
que oui, la demande a peut-être
été formulée
de manière maladroite.
Ce qui est grave, c'est qu'avant
que certains ne sonnent l'alerte,
vous n'ayez rien vu de grave
dans ces pratiques indignes
de notre pays.
Pourquoi, alors même que vous
prétendez que cette demande avait
pour but d'un simple suivi du
déroulement des fêtes religieuses,
le conseil du rectorat affirme
ne pas avoir été prévenu en amont?
Vous avez ciblé les élèves
musulmans pour leur pratique
religieuse.
Le gouvernement a franchi
la ligne rouge.
Madame la ministre,
nous vous reposons solennellement la
question sur l'école, pas sur
les messes le dimanche ni sur les
processions religieuses dans la
rue: les services du ministère
de l'Intérieur ont-ils fait
la demande le 21 avril d'un bilan
sur l'absentéisme des élèves?
Si tel est le cas, nous demandons
à la Première ministre d'offrir
des garanties à la représentation
nationale pour que ces pratiques
ne se reproduisent plus jamais
dans notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Sonia
Backès.
- Sonia Backès: Madame la députée,
je le répète, il n'y a aucun
fichage des élèves dans l'école de
la République en fonction de leur
appartenance religieuse, ne vous
en déplaise.
Je le répète également,
c'est le travail de nos services
de renseignement de suivre
les grandes fêtes religieuses
dans la sphère publique.
Le ramadan concerne une part
importante de nos concitoyens.
C'est aujourd'hui un fait sociétal
qu'il nous appartient de suivre,
y compris à l'école.
Je vous demande d'arrêter de faire
des raccourcis sans fondement.
Quand nos services suivent la fête
des lumières pour la communauté
juive, ils ne sont pas antisémites,
pas plus qu'ils ne sont,
quand ils suivent le ramadan,
islamophobes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Nathalie Da Conceicao
Carvalho.
- Nathalie Da Conceicao Carvalho:
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Action et des
Comptes publics.
Vous avez introduit une nouvelle
obligation déclarative à la charge
des propriétaires de locaux
d'habitation.
La loi de finances pour 2020, qui
a supprimé à compter de 2023 la
taxe d'habitation, a institué
cette nouvelle obligation
déclarative.
Codifiée à l'article 1418 du code
général des impôts, elle doit être
accomplie pour la première fois
avant le 1er juillet 2023.
Cependant, la déclaration doit
être souscrite par voie
électronique.
L'administration indique même
qu'elle s'effectue depuis le
service en ligne "Gérer mes biens
immobiliers" à partir du site des
impôts du gouvernement.
L'administration n'a pas prévu de
formulaire de déclaration papier.
Or de nombreux propriétaires ne
disposent pas d'une résidence
principale équipée d'un accès à
Internet, tandis que d'autres
indiquent ne pas être en mesure de
souscrire la déclaration par voie
électronique.
Aussi, et compte tenu qu'être
obligé de se déplacer dans un
centre des impôts ne saurait
constituer une option, puisqu'il
est de plus en plus difficile
d'avoir quelqu'un au téléphone
pour prendre rendez-vous pour
obtenir un renseignement et que
faire la queue pendant des heures
pour quelqu'un qui travaille n'est
pas envisageable, pourriez-vous
mettre à disposition des Français
un formulaire de déclaration afin
que nos concitoyens puissent
l'envoyer par la poste au Trésor
public?
Est-il prévu d'adresser un
courrier papier aux personnes
dépourvues d'Internet et ne
sachant s'en servir, dans la
mesure où cette information n'a
jusqu'à présent pas été largement
diffusée?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gabriel
Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Madame la députée, vous avez
raison, et vous l'avez rappelé, il
y a une déclaration d'occupation
du logement que doivent réaliser
les propriétaires.
C'est à la suite de la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation, puisque
l'administration fiscale doit
pouvoir connaître le statut des
biens immobiliers pour deux
raisons simples.
Il reste une taxe d'habitation sur
les résidences secondaires, et on
ne veut pas appliquer une taxe
d'habitation sur une résidence
secondaire à ce qui serait une
résidence principale.
Par ailleurs, il faut bien
identifier quelles sont les
résidences principales et quel est
le statut d'occupation des
logements.
Il y a une procédure
dématérialisée qui a été mise en
place.
Ce n'est pas toujours clair pour
les contribuables.
Ce qui doit être réalisé avant le
1er juillet, ce n'est pas
l'intégralité des informations qui
sont demandées sur la plate-forme,
dont certaines sont facultatives,
c'est simplement le statut du
logement.
Est-ce qu'il est occupé ou pas,
est-ce qu'il y a un locataire, et
si oui, qui est ce locataire?
Parfois, certains contribuables
ont pu être perplexes devant la
présentation cadastrale de leur
logement.
Ils se sont posé beaucoup de
questions.
Tous ces sujets peuvent être
validés plus tard.
Ensuite, il faut être capable
d'accompagner les contribuables
qui en ont besoin.
Sur les 340.000 mails qui ont été
reçus, 75% ont déjà reçu une
réponse.
123.000 déclarations ont déjà été
réalisées par les agents.
Quand un contribuable n'a pas
accès à Internet, on peut réaliser
sa déclaration pour lui dans un
centre public ou par téléphone.
Vous demandez si un formulaire
papier peut être mis en place,
cela fait partie des pistes que je
m'engage à examiner.
Notre objectif, c'est
d'accompagner les contribuables et
que personne ne soit pénalisé dans
cette opération.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance des
questions au gouvernement est
terminée.
La séance est suspendue.